hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
this latest edition of quadriga coming
to you from the heart of the German
capital Berlin and this week we're
talking about developments in Turkey
amid growing fears that President Recep
Tayyip Erdogan is creating a one man
state now this week German Chancellor
Angela Merkel has been in Istanbul
expressing what she called her deep
concern about Turkey's commitment to
democracy meanwhile Germany in the rest
of Europe are increasingly dependent on
president Erewhon as a tense standoff
continues between the EU and Turkey over
a crucial deal to reduce the flow of
migrants to Europe a deal that the
Turkish leader has now threatened to
scrap well our topic this week on
quadriga
is aired on our friend the autocrat with
a big question mark and to discuss that
question I'm joined here in the studio
by three excellent observers and
analysts let me introduce them to you
beginning with Maximilian pop who is a
turkey expert from Spiegel magazine who
says the refugee deal between the EU and
Turkey is wrong it strips refugees of
their rights and puts human lives at
risk also with us is andreas Clute of
The Economist who believes that the only
thing worse than sticking to the refugee
G refugee deal with Turkey is not
sticking to that deal and a big welcome
to today ax akahl she's a Turkish
journalist who works for various media
outlets including DW and she says
everyone is in a process of power
centralization but backing away from
democracy will only deepen turkeys
problems and isolation begin with you
and I'd like to begin with Angela
Merkel's visit this earlier this week to
Istanbul where she expressed as she put
it her deep concern about Turkey's
commitment to democracy she also spoke
with members of civil society in Turkey
and Istanbul and I wonder what what
impact those kind of initiatives have in
Turkey is anybody listening actually
I've seen almost no article on Micah's
meeting with the civil society today
with there was a nice
censorship I guess Turkish press wasn't
really invited to the press conference
it was I guess she wanted to give a
message to the German made yeah but a
colleague of ours wrote an article today
we're obviously a Mac said in the
meeting that it's not up to her to fight
for a merger democracy in Turkey that
it's the duty of the Turkish people to
do that
it was coated as such but of course it's
important and it was expected from the
pro EU circles in Turkey that the EU or
politicians would do something prefer to
support them but it's true it's not
matter who's going to you know change
Turkey turkey Turkish politics but I
think it was discussed at that meeting
and it was welcomed that she at least
Metz civil society members what do you
say about that maximally should Angela
Merkel be intervening in Turkish
politics I mean people here get very
angry when know when redditor better one
intervenes in German domestic politics I
think it wouldn't be it wouldn't help
the Turks much I also create that
intervention from German Chancellor
wouldn't really change the human rights
situation in Turkey much and no
intervention didn't make it better in
the past neither so that's that's a
tricky issue she mostly has to do it for
the people in her own country here in
Germany because you feel more more
people you see more and more people
getting uncomfortable with the miracle
being so quiet about human rights
violation in Turkey and with their her
new and strong partnership with with
Richard type Edwin when people feel that
kind of discomfort that is because
German politicians a lot of German
politicians across the board have
recently been saying that mr. elder one
has autocratic ambitions as it's been
put do you share that view is here is he
an alter current in the making I think
he is their tendencies definitely but I
feel I feel always a bit uncomfortable
myself about the discomfort of the
people when we speak about Turkey we
care so much about like the way miracle
talks to add one
we talk so much about the question if if
miracle is in the hands of Aaron what we
talk far too little is about the
situation of the refugees there and that
the consequences the deal has for
Refugees double standards on the German
side I think so yeah mm-hmm so we
undress let's just bring in and res
clutter when we talk about president era
one the people do in germany tend to act
as though he's a despot a fully-fledged
desperate or at least a despot in the
making what what what's his perspective
on all this do you imagine mr. addy ones
perspective I think Oregon is a man of
tremendous vanity in that sense and in a
few other senses he reminds me of
Vladimir Putin but also of other
characters even in German domestic
politics and I think he's viewed his
relationship if you say his view on us
in Germany where we happen to be over
the past year as I think he felt hurt
humiliated in his vanity and like a
child almost I psychologically that's
how I view him in some cases as as Putin
as well I think he felt rejected and is
almost feeling that it's it's up to him
to show his Turks and himself that he
can take revenge specifically what I'm
talking about is when Mercola Angela
Merkel became Chancellor or so about a
decade ago at that time she in contrast
to her predecessor gave Turkey the cold
shoulder that came from within her party
but in rejecting their ambition to to
join the EU and at that point if I'm
correct Aragon was not yet this new
Ottoman autocrat wanted want to be that
he is today but he felt so stiffed by
her that and and probably you know he
lost face but he says I think there he
holds a grudge it's it's as part of the
explanation is probably as simple as
that
so we're talking about today about
wretched tire Bedouins whether he is a
good friend a friend of Germany's
whether he should be a friend of
Germany's whether we should be engaging
in in the refugee deal with Turkey at
this point in time what do you make of
that analysis there I think I agree
I heard one actually when you look at
Turkey turkey sister with it you when
the reform process started actually in
1999 there was a consensus in Turkey
between different political groups
ideologies the EU was a common goal so
you had less dispute and Erin came into
power during that period and they all
agreed on the common goal but when maca
and shellac also so you know it was a
huge mistake by Michael I guess when we
look at at that period now yeah it was I
don't think that Ardoin forgives her we
know that he feels betrayed he's
disappointed and he doesn't trust Merkel
and we can also see that macron knows it
because of the statements she makes
lately because she always underlines
some words you know deep discussions
based on confidence when you when you
elaborate on the word that means there's
a lack of confidence so she's trying to
explain our dawn that she's open to
discussion about the whole thing about
Turkish membership of the EU though I
just wonder maximilan I was reading a
German critic recently who was saying
Turkey is pretending that it wants to be
a member but it doesn't really the EU is
pretending that it wants Turkey in but
it doesn't really is that is that a fair
analysis very very precise description
of what's going on exactly and it's it's
a pity and it's a it's a trauma that it
did we end there to me like this it's
both of you said and it's a missed
chance and I think it will be if we look
back to to these days in like 20 years I
think the decision of miracle in
2005-2006 at the beginning of her
chancellorship to turn away from Turkey
to only speak about this privileged
partnership there I think we will
remember it as one of the crucial
foreign policy mistakes of of her of her
translation okay let's let's go back to
Turkey itself and one thing that is
clear about Turkey at this point in time
is that the country's opposition is
coming under massive pressure from
president air to I'm very much a man
with a mission who is tightening his
stranglehold on power the presidential
system is not a personal request from
rich apt I appear Dewan on the contrary
it's a response to the situation that
turkey currently finds itself in turkey
urgently needs both a presidential
system and a new constitution and anyone
who doesn't agree is going to pay the
price when Elstad Prime Minister Ahmet
Davutoglu include two independent
heroines showed him the door and
replaced him with a more loyal
lieutenant Benaglio theorem and he's
also taken a hard line with the
opposition MPs from the pro-kurdish HDP
party have been stripped of their
parliamentary immunity
Erewhon views our Kurdish politicians as
terrorists and the Turkish press is
forced to remain silent
contrary media providers are taken over
by the government and critical
journalists end up in court is Turkey on
the road to dictatorship
and the rescued it's a question we have
to talk about we've talked about it here
I mean you've been on the show here
often enough where we reflected on this
over you know the question really is now
is he moving towards becoming a dictator
I think he is moving towards doesn't
mean he's fully there but you know the
word dictator comes from ancient Rome
Republican Rome I recently wrote a
little sort of tongue-in-cheek a little
essay on how populism which is also
originated in Republican Rome produces
Little Caesars or Caesar ISM and of
course he is one of the people that we
see a lot of even in America Trump would
like to be a little Caesar if he could
doesn't mean the Republican will let him
but I mentioned Putin we could said
Orban I think he it is part of a trend
after after his perceived rejection he
decided like Putin to turn away from the
West that just rejected him and to build
a neo Ottoman to regain a certain
standing that he feels he's the country
lost and he lost and and everything in
the path he sees again as Putin is to
remove opponents to intimidate or bully
those who disagrees so that he has more
and more power and that has always in
history just meant you're trying to
become a dictator the question is how
far his society will let him become sure
Maximilian when we talk about removing
opponents affirmative atole the Prime
Minister was recently forced to resign
yeah you're a turkey expert tell me what
that tells us about Turkey about mr.
Edwin nothing good I fear because the
the performance of double-talk actually
was not that bad he's a loyalist
he's loyally he has been a loyalist all
but he'd become to ferment what's the
problem yeah I guess there was a reason
and and maybe too successful I mean it
was interesting enough it was like right
after the the EU announced that the the
visa liberalisation is on track that he
was removed this was like the biggest
success in his like maybe like hold
foreign policy career and then just a
few hours after that he is he's out hmm
and that that shows that there is no
place in Turkish politics for a second
man next to to mr. Aaron
okay so truly perhaps a one-man state in
the making are already already in place
there was
interesting dare at the beginning of
that short report that we just seen
there was an interesting statement from
president Erewhon saying that the
situation in which turkey currently
finds itself demands the installation of
a presidential system when he talks
about the situation that turkey
currently finds itself in what might he
be talking about he usually talks about
anti you know he talks about their
threats he talks a lot about terror he
talks about you know he it's really well
known you bashing western bashing he
it's it's the rhetoric it's a populist
rhetoric that we know and he used it is
and it works out you talk of people in
Turkey you ask questions and you see
they're they're afraid from whom yeah
the Westerners they don't want us to
live in peacefully in this country they
support terror it's you know it goes on
like this and I don't think that it not
it doesn't only count but Erin says it
counts what the party members
communicates to their friends to their
families there is a fear in the society
that turkey is left alone yes turkey is
left alone and is isolated which is true
but and lots of Turkish intellectuals
have been calling on Western on Europe
and Western countries to actually to
send send a signal to Turkey where where
where would you all red lines be when is
enough enough the question goes to me go
on there Maximilian I think that the red
line has been crossed much earlier even
before the the refugee deal I mean the
developments since gays he maybe are
just super disturbing I mean I don't
know what it would help to officially
announce a red line I mean we saw what
would that meant in Syria when when
Obama was declaring red lines I don't
know how much red lines help in politics
and I I just think that as we said
before the the troubling thing is that
for Europe the the tools to intervene in
Turkey to put pressure on the on the
Turkish government are very little and
and that's why I am
they in a position where they can only
watch and that's I agree and I think
they talk about red lines in this
context this is naive because red line
and then what what would you propose the
West to Turkey is he has already turned
himself from the West he finds himself
in a difficult neighbor neighborhood and
what is he trying to do I find it quite
short-sighted I think he's driven like
Putin again a lot by psychology more
than a strategic thinking where exactly
is he trying to take Turkey in the next
decade or so and I think he would like
if he could to become a neo Ottoman
leader of the Sunni world and play a
larger role that that way but if you
look at the region he's picking fights
with everyone including shooting down a
Russian jet the other day he in order to
become the powerful person he wants to
be he has to find allies somewhere he's
not doing that right right now so I
don't I I see there is a limit to his
ambition at some point just because he's
not being very smart about it
Turkey very isolated at this point in
time lost a lot of friends in recent
years you would all say I don't have any
dialogue with any other leader than
Macker aye
that is the ironic point anyway I think
I think you've mentioned it as well what
is the alternative what would happen
after you know if you would define red
lines I don't think that's the solution
to anything I've read an article on use
policy related to Russia and mogherini
was elaborating on the fact that it's a
selective engagement and when you look
at it but what's going on between Turkey
and EU it's actually selective
engagement you know to be realistic
Turkey and the EU are cooperating on
fields where they have common interests
and nothing else I think the EU doesn't
do anything you know it's the same thing
with Russia and you know anything with
Iran yeah I mean we do with everyone
what else would one do okay what we do
know is we are doing business with with
turkey at this point in time the refugee
deal between the e between the EU and
okay that we've already mentioned
maximilan you've called it a fast why
yeah exactly exactly because of that
that's what we are doing we are doing
dirty fields with people the problem
here is the refugees have to pay the
price in the end the highest price will
be paid or is paid already by that by
the refugees and I think why and that's
that's that's even more the fault of the
Europeans then of Turkey and I'll
explaining why it was it was promised
and it was promoted the deal was
promised and promoted as something that
would create an alternative to illegal
migration so the refugees wouldn't have
to step on the boats anymore and cross
the Aegean they would have a legal way
to reach Europe and this is not the case
and as long as this is not the case the
whole thing is a farce so far there have
been a few hundred people resettled from
Turkey TV to the EU and already there is
trouble
it seems like this is already the number
the maximum number we can reach this is
not a credible realistic alternative to
illegal migration and that means what
the deal right now is is just
outsourcing the responsibility for
refugees to another country Europe has
done that in the past very often with
Gaddafi in Libya they are now doing it
with Bashir in in in Sudan so they they
don't have much hesitation there and and
and and they are repeating the same
thing with Turkey and that's why I think
it's a farce
okay president words meanwhile you know
we're listening to what Maximilian has
to say the German government in recent
weeks has been arguing that this there's
absolutely no alternative to the refugee
deal is that really true NATO and the EU
external Border Agency Frontex
are patrolling the eastern Mediterranean
heavily making life a lot tougher for
traffickers
the Balkan route is closed fences are a
physical and psychological deterrent and
the EU is also considering plans to give
the majority of funds earmarked for
Turkey to Greece instead that could help
the Greek government finally set up a
functioning infrastructure to provide
adequately for the influx of migrants
asylum applications could be processed
at these new hotspots and applicants who
are turned down could be returned
directly to their home countries from
Greece does the EU still need a refugee
deal with Turkey good question the one
we've got in the making Maximilian says
the deal is a farce
meanwhile and the rest glue to the top
of the show I quoted you as saying the
only thing worse than sticking to the
refugee deal with Turkey is not sticking
to it so explain well first of all I
liked what makes a million said in terms
at heart the deal we have is does
represent outsourcing the problem to
that country just outside our Schengen
borders I think it's out of sight and
out of mind
yes however what is the alternative the
alternative and I think Merkel knew this
to insource it to one member or perhaps
others of the European Union which is
already having a different crisis and
that would be Greece and I think she saw
that I mean her domestic pressure she
got personal fatter that for the time
being because of something that she
officially did not want which was the
solution that the Balkan states with
Austria simply shut their borders I
think that dad dried up this refugee
flow flows as much as everything else
but the but there was a specter that
they would all concrete on Greece and
that we would have potentially lesbos
and caused two islands that would become
huge refugee camps that would not be
good for the refugees either so it faced
with that she said well what is the next
best option in this real world of bad
options okay and and and the only the
only way she had the only thing she had
was to do to do a deal with Turkey
I understand this argumentation I I
still I still don't share it and and I
think I'm I'm a bit troubled by by the
fact that we accepted so much and
they're saying that they're only two
options one is the Viktor Orban Europe
offences and the other is the eu-turkey
deal there is a third option and that
means follow our laws I mean the the
European Constitution the German
constitution they clearly state that
refugees have the right to plot to apply
for asylum within Europe so please let's
go back to this let's work on a third
way
let's work on an alternative and not
accept these two given solutions as
solutions there must be another one just
one thing on that the law is the prop is
a problem here because the existing law
which the law is an ass as the famous
quote says but is that you can apply in
Europe but you apply in the first
country you get to so if you enforce the
law huh you still return the problem to
the countries that are already in crisis
well that's the dublin regulation which
you know the EU would have to work on
obviously the system has to be changed
but it cannot be changed in a way that
it means no more refugees in Europe
that's just denying any responsible
layer it's a big question this refugee
crisis the refugee deal what's the
alternative what's the best way to go
now to move forward I don't think that
there's an alternative if this deal
filled it would have tremendous
consequences on Turkey Germany relations
turkey relations but also turkey would
even get more unpredictable than it is
right now and I fear I fear the
consequences I don't think that there's
an alternative right now but I agree
that there should be alternatives
respecting human rights respecting
refugee rights but when we look at it at
a bilateral level between Turkey and
Germany and the EU it will somehow work
with a little bit changes I guess that's
what they talk in in the Matic circles
that they will wait until October for
the for the visa liberalization both
sides have accepted it but we will hear
you know Ireland will put forward his
own interests he will put his own
interests over the interests of his
people mica will do the same with you
know her political ambitions their
elections next year she will focus on
elaborate on her interests and we will
watch a very tense
negotiations because it will it will
they will talk they will continue to
talk the tension will remain the tension
will increase very fun exercise here an
interesting timing of it to the
Bundestag will vote to call the genocide
a hundred years ago in Armenia a
genocide he will blow a fuse he will
jump up and down and it will all get
worse throughout the summer it's very
unpredictable
for me the interesting question is let's
say he does scupper the deal and say to
hell with it I'm not interested anymore
what will the refugees do then because
of course they go where they expect
success where what will their next route
beat and there are many many options
being discussed everyone is looking for
that that's what's gonna make this
summer unstable okay some sober analysis
from from dais um we've got mr. arrow
I'm blowing a fuse here Maximilian I'd
like to come back to you is is mr. air
Diwan an autocrat first question because
this war would that's the question we've
set for ourselves today in this debate
the the way he governs to the country's
autocratic you okay should we be doing
business with him yes or no in general
yes we should discuss we do discuss with
other grids I have no problem with that
but we have to we have to set up a deal
that guarantees the rights to refugees
and this is not the case that's why it's
a bad deal okay and give me your vision
for your your idea of where German
Turkish relations are likely to go in
the next couple of years given that
there's you know that there are so many
people here in Germany obviously so many
very good people who have their roots in
Turkey yeah this is this is one of the
the traumas we don't talk about much
right now and that is why I agree that
if the deal fails that the consequences
will be bad and then also because of
that because I think this is one of the
last chances those two
of two countries amazingly the EU then
but like also like for German Turkish
regulations they have and if this is now
if this fails I've been gay will like
the mistrust will be even bigger
and I think dark times ahead dark times
out perhaps from Maximilian thank you
dear folks Thank You Maximilian Thank
You Andres hope we given you plenty of
food for thought on relations between
Germany and Turkey if you've enjoyed the
show as much as I have come back next
week bye bye punches